The joe rogan experience.
So you require conflict in order to be engaged.
Yes.
You must have it now.
Well,
I found one of the things that I've found really fascinating about your show was
the episode on Indian Gurus.
Yes.
That was my favorite.
Really.
He's just so fucking bizarre.
The American physicist was the most bizarre to me.
There was a for folks,
Mike,
that was a long time ago.
Mike from California.
Yeah.
Um,
there,
there was a guy,
Swami g's,
I'll you freak out to Patty Satyananda Swami Gee,
what a you of those names.
Yeah.
The Indians have fantastic language.
Their names are amazing.
But there was this character who is this a yoga master,
quasi spiritual leader,
whatever he is.
Um,
you know,
without judging.
And there's this guy named Mike who was a Divo Tay who lived in this guy's off
Schrom I guess.
And Yeah.
Believed that this man could materialize jewelry and objects and the story of
him stomping his foot down and a 50 pound note appeared in his hand.
Like,
this guy's a fucking physicist.
That's right.
Which is so strange.
That was a good one.
It was my favorite,
but my,
one of my favorite moments was you sitting on the edge of the bed talking to him
and you asked him whether or not he said,
try not to take this the wrong way,
but did you have sadness in your life before you,
before you met the sky?
And He,
um,
and he got angry.
He took it a myth and he didn't like that question.
And um,
he said something like,
uh,
what are you asking me?
I'm like,
am I a burnout and burnout?
And his quote was a fascinating because it was about fundamentalism.
Yeah.
He
says like,
I always say that,
uh,
having a breakdown is the,
is like the precursor to fundamentalism.
Decide he was going to say that he had a break.
Yeah.
So I sort of went with the question,
but what he said,
I felt like he was setting me up for that,
but he didn't see himself as a fundamentalist.
And I'm,
it was a really,
it was a misunderstanding.
I normally try and get into the,
the difficult questions a little more gracefully.
And because I had misunderstood what he was saying.
I don't think you did.
I slid into it a bit.
I really don't think he did.
I think he changed gears.
You think?
Yeah,
I think he was sort of that,
you know what happened?
Like the deep story there is that I spent,
that was a weird weekends days,
which was about 10 years ago and I used to try and spend,
it was like a little rule of thumb.
I'd try and I'd find a contributor who I could relate to the most.
Like you take something that seemed really out of whack,
like something that on the face of it you think that how could people really
think it's cool to move to Idaho and not pay taxes and think the UN is going to
invite.
How could people really think?
Indian guru is going to manifest Rolex watches.
They call them cities by meditating and cure cancer by jamming on a keyboard.
Right.
And an old bon Tempe keyboard.
And so,
but the,
the,
the technique we used was to try and find the most likable,
reasonable seeming person who exemplified that belief system.
So you would,
it was like you,
you,
you take a weird sound check but cost it normal.
Like cast it a person who's likable and relatable when Mike was the guy we
thought and when you found that guy and say that and I'll move in,
I'll spend a night with them.
It was like,
it was like to supposed to signal my commitment to the story as well.
So in that story I spent the night,
uh,
Mike's Ashram and um,
but I,
they had very thin mattresses,
although I later found out there were different thicknesses depending on how
committed you were,
you would choose a thinner mattress so you can choose a thick when buying in
real,
I just found a thin one so I put it on.
I thought I had one of the worst nights of sleep in my life and I woke up the
next morning kind of groggy and as you are a offer night sleep,
not just I'm going to bad tempered,
but also just my ci wasn't flowing right now,
wasn't in tune with what was going on around me.
And so when he asks,
he said something about if you're,
you know,
uh,
if you,
you fundamentalist because you've had a breakdown.
And I think,
oh he's saying he had a breakdown.
I think so.
Did you have some sadness in your life?
And then he,
he,
he kind of flipped.
Let's play that and you can find that.
You can find that Jamie,
it's that video that you just showed if you back up about three or four minutes
before that find it is,
is you'll see Louie getting out of bed and he looks very groggy and then he
communicates with this guy and they have this sort of a weird breakdown.
That's also the one where I try and call it.
Cause then the guru says he's a big fan of Siegfried and Roy or David
Copperfield's.
They recover field.
Yeah.
He says he went to Vegas and I took it as a kind of slightly very subtle coded
possible admission that he takes an interest in magic and therefore what he does
is it kind of conjuring.
So I sort of,
I was trying to edge towards getting him to admit,
you know,
like we know that you can't make a Rolex watch appear out of thin air.
Right.
And so why not just,
let's just get that out there and admit that,
you know,
that's what you do.
But he's a guru so he couldn't really admit it.
Yeah.
This is a,
it's like this
just
does foot cause here
he's working on a cosmic level.
Don't take this,
don't take this the wrong way.
Mind who,
was there any sadness in your life before you came to see the Swami and
committed to him?
I'd always have a little saying,
fundamentalism is the aftermath of a nervous breakdown.
You know,
when,
you know,
it's,
it's a little bit of course,
but
did you ever but
come up with that please?
Yeah,
no,
I don't know.
Um,
you know,
the drugs,
she paused this,
all this,
you know,
burn out and then he goes down.
Uh,
uh,
I think these are all towels.
I think he changed gears on you.
I really think his statement,
there's initial statement,
fundamentalism and,
and you know about nervous breakdowns.
I think that's what he's really saying.
Yeah,
I really do.
And then when you confront him on it,
he realizes he's on camera.
This is why the all the,
you know,
he's thinking too much.
He's trying to come up with a way to spin that story in a,
in a better light.
He's not just free flowing,
what's going on in his mind.
He's dancing around the subject trying to wrestle it into a more acceptable,
palatable flight deck.
Good.
I agree that,
but I think what I see my take on it,
it's a,
he,
he's emotionally,
you know,
close to the surface and probably has been through a lot of difficult things.
I,
I mean,
I know what I mean.
I,
I getting dangerously close to kind of diagnosing him,
uh,
in absentia.
But uh,
I,
and I think,
but I also think he's trying to step outside it.
He's trying to say like,
I agree with you,
like,
but I'm not one of them.
Like,
I don't think he thinks that he did have a breakdown.
Well,
it could be bold.
He's trying to play it off.
I mean,
I think maybe he was a lovely guy though.
He was from the bay area happy it's doing it.
He seemed like a very nice guy,
which is one of the interesting aspects of it.
He also seemed fairly intelligent,
but he also claimed to be a total complete scan
dick.
But look,
you know,
Isaac,
I mean,
I don't want to go on a little lecture,
but you know,
Isaac Newton believed in Alchemy,
right?
Did it?
Yeah.
Hailey spent like the last 20 years of his life.
Have you made probably the most important scientific breakthroughs,
you know,
of all time,
the last 20 years of his life?
Kind of calculating the dimensions of Noah's Ark based on biblical,
uh,
information.
I mean,
just Wacko stuff and,
and believed in the philosopher's stone,
in the idea of,
I mean,
so the,
I,
I'm,
I'm constantly surprised and the ways in which your rationality or what we could
think,
choose to think of his rationality,
can coexist with rationalities.
But I'm curious about the fact that you enjoyed the,
the guru story.
Uh,
I,
cause I look back at that and it's not one that I would,
I feel is kind of one of my finest moment.
I loved it.
And I also love the part where you met the woman who was his guru,
this female girl,
and she hugged,
right?
And I had it sort of transcendental experience.
What happened there?
What was that?
Um,
it's hard to explain,
but I,
you know,
sometimes I think,
in a male way,
I'm not that connected to like the deepest sources of my,
of my emotions.
So I,
I don't really know what it was,
but I do think that being hugged is a very simple,
and it's a physical act,
but it's,
uh,
you know,
it,
it creates all kinds of emotions inside of you.
And it just sort of welled up from nowhere.
It was just really odd.
I don't really know exactly what happened.
Um,
I thought about that quite a bit after I watched it.
And one of the things that I took from it was the emotions.
And just the whole group of people waiting in line to hug someone.
The anticipation of it and the love that's in the air.
There's sort of this group minded thing is going on
and there's a lot of music.
Loud music is a lot of people around.
There's a,
there's a,
there's a very heightened atmosphere.
And then she gave me a sort of turbo hug too.
Like she gave me the executive platinum card hog and I think they whispered to
her like,
give this guy,
you know,
the works.
And um,
so she hugged me for longer and she was actually muttering things into my ear.
What was she saying?
I don't,
not words that I recognize,
but it was like,
he was sort of like,
ah
Ha,
they'd have it.
So it was comforting noises.
That's the word.
Poon job as the word for their language.
Well,
it's several levels.
It's UAA spoken Hindi or I'm this or there's a few others too.
Too many to mention.
I would think that just the experience itself of being around all those people
that were in this sort of dancing joyous state in this long line to get to this
woman and she probably had some sincere loving gesture towards everyone as well.
I mean imagine what it would be like to be adored by so many people in such a
large group of people that are established there to come see you and get in line
to hug you.
But then you did it and,
but you are really like move.
But it was,
yeah,
I mean I think as well I was under a lot of pressure.
You know,
when I'm doing those stories,
I feel very pent up and I'm aware that I have one chance to kind of get the
thing that I'm trying to get.
And Weed was one of those classic things where I was supposed to hug her the day
before and then we took a crew break and went for an Indian meal.
And then when we arrived at the,
the hugging tent that packed up and left and I was like,
Oh my God,
we missed the hug.
And then it turned out she was doing two nights,
she was doing like two dates in that city because she was on tour,
like hugging her way around India.
So I was like,
oh,
we're fucked.
How are we going to get the hug now?
Just because like our crew wanted a nice meal and,
and um,
uh,
and so we took it up,
I got to hear another night.
So it was,
it was this long lead up to getting the hog and so it was a tightly wound coil
of,
of anxiety.
So when I finally got there and had the hog,
it was several levels on which I felt just sort of relieved.
Wow.
That's fascinating.
But you know,
religions,
you know,
it's one of lives,
the one in life's mysteries and um,
I'm trying to do a thing on Scientology at the moment and that's a proven quiet,
quite a difficult road.
Well,
religion
is certainly,
it certainly is one of life's great mysteries,
but I think there is also group states of like-mindedness that I find quite
fascinating and you could get them when the people,
I was at a military base once it was a UFC fight for the troops and uh,
they sang the national anthem.
It's in the middle of the Iraq war.
And um,
the,
when they sang the national anthem,
the intensity and the feeling in the air,
the,
that patriotism,
just the emotions involved in,
you're dealing with thousands of people in the audience who have lost loved
ones,
lost friends,
maybe been wounded themselves,
maybe taken lives themselves.
Many of them have shore taken lives themselves.
And the,
the,
the palpable,
the patriotism and the emotion and the invite.
And I am a person who was absolutely against all of these wars,
whether it's the Iraq invasion,
the Afghanistan war.
I thought the whole thing was about money and the whole thing was ill advised.
I thought that the idea of going in for these supposed weapons of mass
destruction was incredibly transparent.
And then I thought that the government and the military industrial complex was
capitalizing on a horrible event in September 11th and using that as an impetus
to go and invade these countries and,
and,
and take over,
you know,
resources.
But that moment when that thing was happening and that person was singing the
national anthem,
it was a soldier that was singing the national anthem and everyone was standing
there proud and the energy in the air and they cheer.
When it was over,
you were ready to go to war.
I mean,
you are ready to support the troops.
You're ready to not just support the troops but support the war.
You're ready to back them.
I mean,
there's this weird thing that happens,
these group minded sort of states that should,
did you get into a kind of altered consciousness in that moment?
I felt something for sure.
Did you feel I could have easily cried if I,
if I coaxed myself into it or if I entertain those thoughts,
the feeling,
I mean,
I was working at the time I was,
it was,
you know,
I was there for the ultimate fighting championship.
And,
um,
but the,
the state of mind,
the,
the group state was fucking intense and it was,
it was palpable.
It was tangible.
It was in the air.
And you know,
this is coming from a person who I believe that it's very important to have
military.
I believe that there are bad people in the world.
I believe that there's sometimes no other solutions.
I mean,
I don't believe in pacifism when you're dealing with thugs and evil people in
the world.
I believe that.
But I also believe that there's good people that are sent into bad situations
for all the wrong reasons,
by people that are trying to make money.
But in that state,
in that state was being there with all those soldiers being there with all these
people,
man,
you got swept away by it.
He just kept carried away by this.
This intense feeling of patriotism is an indescribable because you could feel
the emotions of those people that are in that,
that,
that room.
And I wonder if that's similar to what you were experiencing when you were
there.
I'm sure.
I'm sure it very close.
And,
and,
and it's not the only time when,
I mean,
if the only time I think I felt that exact sort of emotion of as a sort of
whatever that was at a religious transcendence.
But I've,
you know,
there's plenty of times when you are around people.
I mean,
in a way,
a lot of the stories I do are about the altered consciousness of being exposed
to people who believe things passionately.
And that slight sense of Stockholm Syndrome that sets in when you were there for
prolonged periods,
you know,
and,
and the,
and the weird,
um,
Cha did the change in consciousness that takes place.
You know,
I,
I did a story where I was with the Phelps clan,
the Westboro Baptist church,
and I was spent three weeks with them.
Uh,
if I did two different things,
but for the first one I was at for three,
which is called the most hated family in America.
And it was really odd because when you're inside there,
there are little compound in their,
in their castle imbibing there and their doctrine around the clock,
stuff that seems really weird and hateful on the outside starts to seem mundane.
You know,
you're still able to step outside of their lives.
I'm here to do a job and this is wrong.
But you,
you get a nice,
the ties,
your mind,
your mind starts to get influenced.
It's really
strange.
I would imagine it is.
Um,
I've found the Phelps one very fascinating because of the one guy that came
there to film a documentary on them and then became one of them.
He joined up Steve.
Yeah,
he's very high up there now.
Steve,
he's,
and his daughter,
uh,
left.
Um,
a couple of years ago we went back and did a followup because a couple of the
people we featured in the first one then left.
But Steve almost,
you could argue by dint of having been born outside the church was compensating
by being even more hardcore cause he was the fiercest and the most,
um,
in conversation.
He was the hardest and the most,
um,
the most abusive.
I get most verbally full of bile.
And he also,
when you questioned anything that he was saying,
what starting salting you.
Yeah,
yeah.
And aggressively and salting you and I found that fascinating as well.
It wasn't just that you could have questions.
It was that,
what do you fucking idiot.
It was like immediately this aggressive sort of,
he
told me I was the most,
I can't remember the phrase he said,
it sound like the most iniquitous are the most evil man in the history of the
earth or one of the three most evil men.
He said,
you're right up there with punches.
Like I was one of the three most evil men of all time,
like,
you know,
way beyond Hitler.
And the reason was,
the reason was because I'd been exposed to the teachings,
like I'd been given a special opportunity.
Like I was blessed beyond measure because I had been exposed for three weeks to
the pure teachings of the only people preaching salvation on earth.
And having seen that and still rejected it,
then that put me way beyond the Pale.
I found it incredibly fascinating.
How effective of a guy who sucks at speaking is at running a cop.
Like he's a terrible orator.
He's not like this really charismatic ramps.
The main guy.
He's very old now.
Like he's in his time.
He could,
he could do it.
I thought he was,
I think you're being a little unfair.
You remember the bit where he says,
I'm going to eat.
You can eat your babies.
Like he,
he's still,
he's very old and,
and kind of decrepit,
but he still cranks it up and he goes,
you're going to eight.
You're made A's.
See,
I don't agree.
I follow.
So one note,
it was like death metal.
You can eat.
It's terrible.
I mean,
it was just so obvious.
I,
it's just there.
There's,
who do you like Billy Graham?
Like what preaching style do you prefer?
A Sam Kinison this is my favorite.
Um,
I,
I just think that there are people who are better at it than Phelps.
Phelps is so negative and so abrasive.
I think there's almost his,
he's so believably evil bill,
he starts dearly beloved.
He did has a slow bill,
right?
And then he ramps it up and then he get,
he hits his,
his kind of power chorus,
if you can eat your babies.
I think there's something when someone's unbelievably evil and aggressive where
you don't want them to be angry at you.
So you're willing to sort of like bend your mind to what they're saying and
accept it and allow it in.
And that's what I felt watching that guy.
And I've seen that in him before and in his speeches I've tried to sort of
rationalize or understand what's going on when,
when he talks,
why,
when anybody gets sucked into all this evil,
hateful talk and not question it.
But I think it's,
he's so over the top and so aggressive that he's frightening to people.
Like when you sat down with them and talk to them about the thing.
I mean by and large,
they don't really make converts.
They make a few,
but he's not trying to recruit,
um,
new personnel.
If anything,
it's the opposite.
They re they view it as a,
um,
as a confirmation of the holy status and of their salvation that they're
rejected because there's some verse somewhere in the Bible saying,
you will be hated of men and people will throw things at you.
It's somewhere in the Bible.
And so every time someone says you're full of it,
you're scum,
we hate you.
That what they hear is,
yes,
we are,
we're saved.
So and so when he,
um,
and he,
so like 90% of the people in there were born into it and a family members and in
fact they Lou,
they hemorrhage membership constantly.
They kick people out.
So when he's preaching,
he's not thinking,
how do I get new new followers?
Well,
I'm not saying that he's thinking that.
I'm wondering the effectiveness of retaining anyone out of tickets even.
Well there I guess there is the main effectiveness is that,
um,
I don't know what it,
well,
you would know obviously much more than I,
you were there for three weeks deeply embedded into that organization.
He hated me.
Gramps did.
And he was one of the few times where you try and do an interview with someone
who clearly can't stand you.
And I did an,
I said something like,
how,
how can you really believe that there's no like even if you accept that what you
say is true,
you know that position is,
there is no other church in the world that is preaching the doctrine.
I said,
how would you even know?
Like there could be some tiny church in Nigeria that's preaching the exact same
message.
How would you know?
You wouldn't even know.
He goes and he says,
oh,
I know about them.
And I asked another question.
It goes asked and answered and I also,
and another because asked an answer and he just kept saying,
Austin answered,
which is a legal term.
I mean,
you know,
what do you do?
What did you do?
Then there's nothing you could chuck.
He's the epitome of a close minded person.
I mean he is closed minded,
not just that,
but this arrogant assumption that he's the man with the word of God and that it
comes out of this angry old fuckheads face.
You know,
it's,
it's a,
it's an amazing thing that this guy is able to put together this group.
I mean,
I just,
this is the moment where he sat down and talked to this guy,
you know,
it was,
how long have you been with him by then?
Thickness was,
I'm trying to think.
It was the end of it.
We made three trips each of a week.
This was the second trip last day.
If you had just a little knowledge of the Bible,
you will know that what you just said is stupidity in Spain.
I don't know how to deal with a question like that.
Yes,
we just took down.
Sorry.
You've got the duty to know the Bible as well as I do.
Why?
Because you are human beings called God Almighty major and got all my,
are going to send your ass to hell.
Is it accurate to say that you regard the Westboro Baptist church is the only
church giving biblical preaching according to the word?
No.
The answer your question is yeah,
no,
it was five minutes.
Well,
but I already talked to them.
So there's three left.
Um,
the real fucking shitty,
nasty preaching that is according to the word of God is fancy.
Ashton answered next question.
As far as your concerned.
We got it.
Yeah.
I mean this is angry shitty man
who's able to get a bunch of people to listen to him.
My,
he gets his five kids,
his kids and his grandkids.
Well,
how many people were there?
It seems like there was a little 20 or 30 or 90.
Okay.
That's hip hop.
Yeah.
He had 11.
Not yet.
I think I want to get this right.
I think it was like 12 kids,
but for them had left the church and each of them had had quite a few kids.
But I think,
um,
I think if you're an EGOMANIAC,
number one,
number two,
if whatever reason you cleave to a certain kind of dogmatic religious outlook is
probably not that difficult to,
to,
to run,
to have a cult.
Unfortunate.
But I think you're right.
You know,
it's shocking.
But I think you're right.
I've,
I've often said that all you have to do is speak confidently and clearly and
most people would be like,
I can't.
Yeah.
And have no compunction about saying that you speak the word of God or whatever
it is.
That's really all you have to do,
right?
You have to be the guy with the answers.
You have to be the guy that absolutely not just the answers like as a human,
but the answer is from above from it.
I mean,
have you read the new Manson book then you Charles Manson Book by Jeff Gwyn?
It came out last year.
No,
I try not to read anything that comes out about Manson.
Uh,
I'll,
I'll ask you why in a second.
But when you read it,
it's like,
Oh my word.
You just have to be kind of come out with a few kind of riddles that you've
learned from street pimps and people fall into your lap or so it would seem,
you made me,
I ain't sure.
Garbage man.
He people made me,
I'm your product.
All that fucking maniacal shit.
I think that that guy's the Bob hope of serial killers.
You know,
cause Bob hope was a comedian that never really made anybody that in my
generation laugh.
Like,
we always knew him as a comedian,
but it's like just really wasn't funny.
Manson was never scary to me.
Like there's some real serial killers that we're fucking terrifying.
But when you think of serial killers,
it's always Manson.
Manson Manson is the guy,
the crazy guy,
the wild guy.
Cause he carved a fucking swastika in his head.
But if you,
I mean Henry Lee Lucas,
the guy from that,
they made that movie about him.
Henry Portrait of a serial killer allegedly killed somewhere around 60 people,
you know,
and I was with medicine.
The,
I think the reason people are fascinated with medicine,
it's cause he didn't kill right?
He got other people to yas because he got the,
the,
the children that he,
uh,
he sent them out of Tex Watson was his big killer,
right?
Tech who's become a born again Christian.
And I think you're right.
It's children's books or something fucking creepy.
That,
and you know what?
A number of them still believe,
you know that Charles,
that Charlie's still are of course,
otherwise they're idiots.
Okay.